[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und anne gellinek
guten abend wir beginnen mit einer
räuberpistole ein schließfach voller
geld verworrene aktiengeschäfte bei
denen der staat um milliarden euro
geprellt wird dazu ein finanzamt das
zwar wind von der sache bekommt aber
zunächst kein geld zurückfordert das
allerbeste an der geschichte aber ist
die rolle des damaligen bürgermeisters
der einen der beschuldigten einen banker
kennt und jetzt deutscher bundeskanzler
ist klingt wie ein mittelmäßiges
drehbuch ist aber die geschichte des
sex-skandals in hamburg die frage die
der dort tagenden untersuchungsausschuss
seit anderthalb jahren zu klären
versucht ist hat olaf scholz damals
bürgermeister die in illegale
aktiengeschäfte verstrickte bank gedeckt
der kanzler war heute als zeuge geladen
ralf zimmermann von siewert war dabei
der bundeskanzler auf stippvisite in
seiner heimatstadt gut gelaunt und als
ob nichts wäre
dabei wurde sein auftritt heute mit
spannung erwartet im hamburger rathaus
wo regierung und parlament also senat
und bürgerschaft gleichermaßen ihren
sitz haben doch das bürgermeisteramt von
einst wirft lange schatten die er nicht
so recht los wird noch in den letzten
tagen kamen neue fragen auf zu comics
und der hamburger warburg bank zum
beispiel ob es tatsächlich gelöscht die
e mails in seinem vorzimmer im
kanzleramt gab oder was bei seinen drei
treffen mit bankern in 2016 und 17
besprochen und beschlossen wurde doch
scholz nahm selbstbewusst auf seinem
alten stuhl des ersten bürgermeisters
platz und konnte wie schon bei seiner
ersten vernehmung vor eineinhalb jahren
mit erinnerungslücken zu vielen der
einzelnen fragen das ist für uns
deswegen auch schlecht weil wir
natürlich aufklärung machen wollen und
jemand der sich an nichts erinnern kann
wie sollen wir da aufklären warum es
gewisse probleme der hamburgischen
verweis finanzverwaltung gegeben hat
bislang nicht geklärt etwa ist ob er
johannes kahrs ehemaliger spd
bundestagsabgeordneter und schillernder
strippenzieher bei der entscheidung der
finanzbehörden
2016 auf die steuerrückzahlung von 47
millionen euro zu verzichten eine rolle
gespielt und mit stolz darüber
gesprochen hat dass bei kas gegen den
wegen beihilfe zur steuerhinterziehung
ermittelt wird
214.000 euro im schließfach gefunden
wurden lässt seine politische
vergangenheit noch fragwürdiger
erscheinen doch scholz sieht auch hier
keinen erklärungsbedarf den
untersuchungsausschuss hingegen für ab
sofort überflüssig
gibt zu ich hatte mich darauf
eingerichtet dass es viel länger dauert
aber die tatsache dass es dann schnell
und zügig war spricht vielleicht auch
für die tatsache dass alles nun
mittlerweile auf dem tisch liegt und man
auch die klare schlussfolgerung ziehen
kann da war nichts es hat keine
einflussnahme gegeben aus der hamburger
cdu hingegen gab es nach dem auftritt
von scholz heute einen ausdrücklich
ernst gemeinten vorschlag wenn man also
eine derart große amnesie aufweist gibt
es tatsächlich eine forensische
möglichkeit durch hypnose zeugen wieder
an dinge zu erinnern also erinnern zu
lassen dann können die im
unterbewusstsein hervorholen das war
schon eine ernst gemeinte frage er
wollte sie dann ins lächerliche ziehen
und auch in berlin will die cdu
nachfragen an scholz zu seiner
verantwortung im hamburger comex skandal
richten es spricht sehr viel dafür dass
wir olaf scholz auch in den
finanzausschuss des deutschen
bundestages einladen werden hamburg war
das einzige bundesland das
steuerbetrügern hier einen erlass
gewähren wollte und das unter der
politischen verantwortung eines
regierungschefs olaf scholz so bleiben
von der zweiten vernehmung des kanzlers
in der tat nicht mehr erkenntnisse als
von der ersten vor gut einem jahr und
auch bürgerinitiativen wie etwa finanz
wende nehmen dem ehemaligen hamburger
bürgermeister seine vielen
erinnerungslücken schlicht nicht ab
und unsere hauptstadt korrespondent in
schaag unterlag banerjee hat die aussage
von olaf scholz in hamburg beobachtet
schack und der kanzler sagt ja er könne
sich im einzelnen nicht mehr an die
gespräche mit den warburg bänkern
erinnern wie glaubwürdig war sein
auftritt heute im ausschuss na ja das
kommt wahrscheinlich darauf an wie man
da fragt wir haben ja gehört dass olaf
scholz selbst sehr zufrieden gewesen ist
mit der ganzen veranstaltung er sich
darum noch einmal darin bestätigt dass
also an den vorwürfen nichts dran ist
und er bekam im ausschuss selbst
natürlich auch unterstützung von spd
seite da wurde darauf hingewiesen dass
doch insgesamt 50 zeuginnen und zeugen
schon zu protokoll gegeben hätten dass
man sich von scholz oder auch von jemand
anderem nicht politisch beeinflusst
gefühlt hätte bei den warburg
entscheidungen also da stehen dann zwei
meinungen gegeneinander olaf scholz hat
hier auch nochmal sein politisches
wirken in die waagschale geworfen und
darauf hingewiesen dass er die comics
die jetzt grundsätzlich für für
strafwürdig halte und grundsätzlich
gegen steuerhinterziehung mit in seiner
politischen karriere gearbeitet habe und
immer für ein politisch gerechtes
steuersystem also da hat er nochmal
versucht das bild zu zeichnen das ist
auch unsinnig sei eben das mit blick auf
seine politische hat sein politisches
wirken vorzuwerfen man hatte am ende den
eindruck dass alle aus diesem ausschuss
rausgegangen sind mit der haltung die
sie schon hatten als ihr eingegangen
sind trotzdem merkt hinterland der
verdacht der im raum steht ist ja dass
olaf scholz und sein damaliger
finanzsenator und jetzige bürgermeister
von hamburg peter tschentscher mit der
beschuldigten warburg-bank gekungelt
haben indem sie dafür gesorgt hätten
dass die bank zunächst kein geld
zurückzahlen musste kann dieser verdacht
für einen von den beiden nochmal
gefährlich werden politisch ja der
verdacht kann dann gefährlich werden
wenn er nochmal erhärtet werden kann
also wenn es noch weitere belege dafür
gibt der obmann der linken im ausschuss
hatte heute noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen momentan hat der ausschuss
diese belege nicht kann also immer nur
versuchen nachzuweisen dass es
widersprüche in den aussagen gibt was
schwierig ist wenn sich olaf scholz
immer wieder auf erinnerungslücken
berufen es wurde auch darauf hingewiesen
dass die verantwortung jetzt zum teil
rüber geschoben wurde zur peter
tschentscher also wenn an einer stelle
noch etwas rauskommt dann kann es
tatsächlich für beide schwierig werden
politisch ist es auf jeden fall so dass
etwas hängen bleibt weil die
glaubwürdigkeit in diesen befragungen je
mehr befragungen es gibt natürlich
angekratzt wird das war vermutlich nicht
die schönste woche des bundeskanzlers
erst die unwidersprochene holocaust
äußerung des palästinenserpräsidenten
dann ärger mit der gas umlage jetzt u
ausschuss hat scholz ein größeres
problem mit krisenkommunikation ja
tatsächlich hat sich da in dieser woche
gezeigt dass man wohl auch im kanzleramt
dass es nicht in allen situationen ganz
glücklich verläuft wenn olaf scholz
reagiert oder reagieren sollte was
auffällig war in dieser woche das nach
dem vorfall mit dem
palästinenserpräsidenten abbas es
nochmal zwei auftritte von chance
gegeben hat wo er sich auf statements
beschränkt hat das heißt es nur kurz vor
die kameras getreten hat dann keine
nachfragen mehr zugelassen heute ist das
auch so gewesen obwohl er sich sichtlich
wohlgefühlt hat nach dem ausschuss das
deutet schon darauf hin dass man in
dieser woche keine weitere
kommunikationspanne riskieren wollte und
das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch ein
zeichen dank intel manager für diese
einordnung live aus hamburg die
meistgestellten fragen und die
dazugehörigen antworten zur comex affäre
finden sie auch auf zdf heute.de und in
der zdf- heute- app
zu unserem nächsten thema deutschland
will eine eigenständige außenpolitik
machen die über den europäischen
tellerrand hinausschaut dazu gehört auch
im indopazifik präsenz zu zeigen und so
kommt es dass die deutsche luftwaffe zum
ersten mal in ihrer geschichte mit
kampfflugzeugen an einem manöver in
australien teilnimmt die probleme der
deutschen bundeswehr flogen allerdings
mit bei der verlegung von sechs euro
fightern kamen zunächst nur fünf beim
zwischenstopp in singapur an normen
odenthal berichtet von einer dennoch
gewaltigen logistik leistung top gun
feeling inklusive
das lohnniveau in der luft braucht
absolutes feingefühl in 8700 metern höhe
bei fast 900 kilometern pro stunde
muster stutzen ins körbchen dann fließt
der sprit vom tanker zum jet alle zwei
stunden etwa fliegt der eurofighter an
den tropf
zeitpunkt zu finden wo wir gutes wetter
haben wo der schlauch stabiles und wo
wir auch keine keine manöver vor uns
haben wir brauchen ein gerades stück
strecke damit sich der eurofighter nur
darauf zu konzentrieren kann diesen korb
zu treffen der nicht groß ist es kann
nicht immer klappen aber
auf dieser reise gibt es reichlich
trainingsmöglichkeiten mehr als 12.000
kilometer die eurofighter schaffen das
sind gut 20 stunden schneller als
gedacht trotz kurzer zwischenstopps und
eben dutzenden aufstand manövern in der
luft die übung am anderen ende der welt
ist für die luftwaffe eine große sache
nie zuvor hat sie in dieser ferne
operiert das ziel beweisen dass man es
kann einsatzfähigkeit wo immer
erforderlich wir müssen und das zeigt er
die jetzige politische situation in
europa sehr deutlich schnell reagieren
können und wenn wir dann den auftrag
kriegen dann müssen wir im besten fall
innerhalb eines tages in einem gebiet
sein wo einfach politischen spannungen
oder vielleicht krisentief herrscht der
indopazifik selbst ist ein brennpunkt
zwischen west und ost usa und china mit
eskalationsgefahr in terror doch mit
konflikten vor der eigenen der
europäischen haustür was treibt das
deutsche interesse in dieser fernen welt
region an wir haben zum einen natürlich
wirtschaftliche interessen wir wollen
dass er stabil bleibt wir haben auch
werte geleitete interessen wir wollen
natürlich im zuge von und des aufstiegs
chinas auch deutlich machen wir wollen
eben nicht dass das recht des stärkeren
in dem raum dominiert und insofern
glaube ich ist ein ansatz zu zeigen dass
wir eben auch bereits in sicherheits-
und verteidigungspolitik da ein bisschen
mehr zu machen mit vorsicht jedoch um
bloß nicht in einen konflikt gezogen zu
werden denn chinas argwohn ist groß das
manöver für peking eine provokation
allen beteuerungen zum trotz die
luftwaffe fliegt hier nur auf
internationalen luftstrassen wir sind
völlig unbewaffnet und ich sehe in
keinster weise dass wir irgendeinen
signal gegen jemanden senden sondern wir
senden ein signal für die partner die
wir in dieser region haben 17 nationen
100 flugzeuge das manöver down under hat
dimension die luftwaffe ist mit sechs
eurofightern dabei und wagt sich damit
ungewohnt weit vor geografisch
militärisch politisch
auch wenn für süddeutschland heute
regengüsse angekündigt sind insgesamt
dauert die trockenheit an und beschert
uns einen negativ rekord nach dem
anderen
der sonst mächtige rein stellenweise ein
rinnsal schon fürchten die
binnenschiffer dass sie bald ganz auf
dem trockenen sitzen überhaupt fühlen
sich die flugkapitäne benachteiligt ihm
fehlt nicht nur regen sondern auch
politische unterstützung für den
umstrittenen ausbau von wasserstraßen
dominik müller rosell ist auf dem rhein
ein stückchen mitgefahren
der rhein zieht sich zurück
samt und kiesbänke treten zu tage die
das wasser sonst verbirgt
für schiffsführer rollt kippe heißt das
volle konzentration auf die fahrrinnen
einen meter fünfzig liegt sein schiff
tief im wasser an manchen besonders
heiklen stellen hat er gerade noch rund
30 cm platz unterm kiel hier gas beck
vorsichtig fahren
sagen wir die ganze zeit 40 zentimeter
und was vielleicht auch gleich ein
bisschen
das habe ich gewusst dass kommt
steinbrocken über die der
schiffspropeller schrammt sind das eine
problem bei niedrigwasser das andere
rolf kiepe kann sein schiff kaum noch
beladen nur 700 statt mehr als 2000
tonnen mineralien transportiert er von
rotterdam nach rein wohl bei koblenz für
seinen kunden einem glashersteller 70
prozent seines frachtraums bleiben leer
das ist schlecht eigentlich für alle
beteiligten des für unseren kunden
schlecht das ist für uns schlecht wir
müssen trotzdem unsere unkosten sind im
grunde nicht wesentlich niedriger als
wenn wir hier mit den vollen schiff
hinfahren aber naja wir geben unser
bestes dass wir das machen und dass wir
unsere kunden zufrieden stellen trotz
des blöden situation eine niedrigwasser
zuschlag bekommen die binnenschiffer
immerhin von ihren kunden doch wer soll
die liegengebliebene fracht
transportieren denn nicht nur die
schiffe auch die lkw und die bahn fahren
längst am limit die verkehrspolitik habe
den rhein als europas wichtigste
wasserstraße viel zu wenig auf dem radar
ärgert sich rolf gibt es wird schon seit
jahren über eine bestimmte tiefe hier
gesprochen die eigentlich immer
garantiert werden soll es passiert aber
im grunde nichts so ich glaube dass die
binnenschifffahrt in deutschland da
lange vernachlässigt worden ist
und ich glaube das ist auch vielen gar
nicht klar ist was für ein wichtiger
verkehrsträger die binnenschifffahrt ist
die mündung der sieg in den rhein sonst
ein ordentlicher fluss nun ein rinnsal
wolf keeper hofft dass die pegel wieder
etwas steigen in den nächsten tagen vor
allem auf dem rhein ich sag mal wenn wir
20 30 zentimeter meerwasser kriegen dann
ist die situation für alle beteiligten
schon besser dann können die großen
schiffe auch wieder
ohne große probleme fahren sagen wir mal
so und dann haben wir statt 30 prozent
ladung ja vielleicht 50 prozent ladung
ein schiff was ja doch schon eine ganze
menge aus macht
immer eine handbreit wasser unterm kiel
wünschen sich die schiffer traditionell
in diesem jahr dringender denn je
die nachrichten beginnen mit russischem
gas das immer spärlicher fließen gundula
gause und ende august wird die
gaspipeline nord stream 1 für drei tage
bis einschließlich 2 september komplett
abgeschaltet das teilte der russische
energiekonzern gazprom mit und
begründete dies mit routinemäßigen
wartungsarbeiten
seit juni sind die gaslieferungen aus
russland bereits stark reduziert gazprom
lieferte nach eigenen angaben vor dem
krieg täglich
167 millionen kubikmeter gas ab dem
dritten september sollen es wie heute 33
millionen kubikmeter pro tag seien die
präsidenten frankreichs und russlands
makro und putin haben sich in einem
telefonat für eine baldige inspektion
des ukrainischen atomkraftwerks sapori
schwer ausgesprochen so bald wie möglich
sollten kontrolleure der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde das kraftwerk
besichtigen bestätigte der kreml auf dem
gelände des akw kommt es immer wieder zu
beschuss wofür sich russland und die
ukraine gegenseitig beschuldigen im
ukrainischen charkow dauern die
russischen angriffe an nach ärztlichen
angaben ist die zahl der todesopfer seit
donnerstag auf 21 gestiegen
am zweiten tag seines besuchs in der
ukraine hat un-generalsekretär görisch
in odessa die wiederaufgenommenen
getreideexporte gelobt und zugleich eine
ausweitung der lieferungen gefordert
nicht nur ukrainische sondern auch
russische nahrungsmittel exporte sollten
möglich sein unter beachtung der
sanktionen das sei wichtig für die
weltmärkte die entwicklungsländer und
die preisentwicklungen die ursache des
massenhaften für sterbens in der oder
ist immer noch nicht geklärt entwarnung
gab die landesregierung mecklenburg
vorpommerns
zumindest für den deutschen teil des
stettiner haffs hier seien wasserproben
unauffällig bei der ursachensuche sollen
jetzt auch satellitenbilder helfen
fachleute hoffen auf hinweise ob
eventuell chemikalien in die oder
eingeleitet wurden nach behördenangaben
stieg der flusspegel kurz vor
bekanntwerden der katastrophe um fast 30
cm
nach wochenlanger trockenheit geht in
teilen bayerns und baden württembergs
derzeit dauerregen wieder besonders
extremes wetter droht am alpenrand es
sind ausläufer der unwetter die gestern
bereits über österreich hinweg gezogen
waren dort kamen fünf menschen ums leben
zehntausende haushalte waren
zwischenzeitlich ohne strom der verkehr
im süden des landes lahmgelegt
wenn ein riesenkonzern wie apple
plötzlich alle seine kunden auffordert
doch bitte ganz schnell ein sicherheits
update durchzuführen
dann ahnt man dass es ein problem gibt
ein riesenproblem die entstandenen
sicherheitslücken ermöglichen hacker
nämlich so gut wie alles mit einem
iphone ipad oder mac computer
anzustellen private fotos versenden
schätzt mitlesen kontodaten aussperren
passwörter ändern simon gubisch und till
schach berichten
es ist ein harmloser update hinweis
versteckt in den einstellungen des
iphones doch was sich dahinter verbirgt
hat es in sich gleich zwei gravierende
sicherheitslücken sind auf apple-geräten
entdeckt worden betroffen sind fast alle
neueren geräte der marke iphone ipad und
mac computer schätzungsweise mehrere
hundert millionen nutzer weltweit die
eine sicherheitslücke betrifft das
sogenannte webkit es ist ein internes
programm das von apps und browsern
verwendet wird die andere lücke ist im
kernel der schnittstelle zwischen
betriebssystem und hardware des gerätes
gerade die kombination aus diesen beiden
sicherheitslücken macht die lage so
brisant schon aus wenn ich der
internetseite besucht die manipuliert
ist dass wir dort ein computerschädling
untergejubelt wird und dann im nächsten
schritt ist man damit also dann auch in
der lage auf die wir auf dem kölner
sozusagen das die herzkammer des
betriebssystems zuzugreifen wenn hacker
hierhin vordringen kann das gerät nicht
mehr unterscheiden ob es sich um einen
echten nutzer oder um ein nutzer über
das internet handelt handy oder computer
sind dann unter der vollständigen
kontrolle des hackers
damit ist prinzipiell alles möglich was
ein nutzer auch mit dem handy machen
könnte daten können ausgelesen und
manipuliert werden passwörter fotos
e-mails wie lange die sicherheitslücke
schon existiert darauf gibt es von apple
keine antwort
ist das nicht auszuschließen dass die
sicherheitslücke längere zeit unentdeckt
war und dann auch ausgenutzt wurde so
eine sicherheitslücke die bis in den
kern des betriebssystems
betrifft die wird sehr sehr gerne von
geheimdiensten für cyber spionage
eingesetzt
jetzt wo die lücke bekannt ist könnte
das noch mehr hacker auf den plan rufen
warnen experten
daher ist für alle nutzer ein umgehendes
update dringend empfohlen egal ob nutzer
von apple microsoft oder google ganz
sicher ist im internet eben niemand
scooter sind die pest oder eine tolle
erfindung je nach betrachtungsweise in
jedem fall sind die elektro roller
vergleichsweise neu auf deutschlands
straßen so neu dass die verkehrs
gesetzgebung sie noch gar nicht richtig
auf dem schirm hat sie fallen nämlich in
die kategorie von fahrzeugen die sich
langsamer als 20 stundenkilometer
bewegen und sind damit von der
gefährdungs haftung ausgeschlossen
das sollte sich ändern sagen
verkehrsexperten christoph schneider
berichtet es war ein groß angekündigter
wurf auf der verkehrsministerkonferenz
im april 2009 10 der damalige
bundesverkehrsminister andreas scheuer
erlaubt mit seinen kolleginnen und
kollegen aus den ländern äußerst
medienwirksam den elektrorollern die so
genannten scootern den betrieb im
straßenverkehr schon damals ist andreas
scheuer eines klar
ich weiß es wird auch mit neuen
fahrzeugen sicherlich konflikte geben ob
mit radfahrern oder mit fußgängern oder
mit autofahrern deswegen müssen wir uns
das genau anschauen genau anschauen nach
gut drei jahren im straßenverkehr
gehören die elektro kleinstfahrzeuge zum
alltag auf den straßen hierzulande in
den städten stehen sie fast an jeder
ecke doch die wendigen gefährte machen
auch probleme sind treiber bei den
unfallzahlen
2020 wurde nie scooter erstmals in der
unfallstatistik erfasst
da registrierte das statistische
bundesamt noch rund 2200 unfälle mit
personenschaden leicht verletzt wurden
gut 1900 fünf personen starben
2021 haben sich die zahlen in zwei
bereichen mehr als verdoppelt gut 5500
unfälle leicht verletzt rund 4900 die
zahl der getöteten blieb gleich bleibt
die frage wer haftet bei schäden der
verursacher und halter würde man meinen
doch die scooter sie unterliegen nicht
der sogenannten gefährdungshaftung
gefährdungshaftung
bedeutet dass man unabhängig von einem
verschulden für die gefahr haftet die
von einem gefährlichen gegenstand zum
beispiel ausgeht wie ein kraftfahrzeug
doch diese gefährdungs haftung gilt
nicht für fahrzeuge die mit weniger als
20 km h unterwegs sind also für die
scooter so sieht es das
straßenverkehrsgesetz vor wenn sie als
fußgänger beispielsweise über eine
scooters stolpern dann liegt aus unserer
sicht auf der hand dass der e scooter
halter mit schuldig ist und auch haften
muss und dass das opfer schadensersatz
erhalten kann wenn sie aber in dieser
situation nach aktuellem recht sind dann
müssen sie erst mühsam nachweisen dass
da ein schuldhaftes verhalten vorliegt
und kommen nicht automatisch an den
schadensersatz das muss sich ändern
fordern die experten auf dem
verkehrsgerichtstag in goslar
der gesetzgeber muss eigentlich im
grunde genommen ist genauso behandeln
wie autos oder wie kraftfahrzeuge denn
dort ist völlig klar wenn es zu einem
unfall kommt dann haftet auch der kraft
fahrzeughalter nun ist die politik
gefordert die vorschläge aus goslar
umzusetzen das haftungsrecht modernen
verkehr es hat dringend ein update nötig
und hier geht es weiter mit nachrichten
aus der wirtschaft und mit gundula an
den finanzmärkten halten sich die
inflationssorgen anlass waren heute die
erzeugerpreise in deutschland die im
juli enorm zugelegt haben das
statistische bundesamt bilanziert den
stärksten anstieg innerhalb eines jahres
seit beginn der erhebung 1949 valerie an
der börse das treibt die preise was tut
die ezb sie wird wohl auf diese hohe in
nationen reagieren müssen die zinsen
weiter anheben
davon kann man wohl ausgehen die frage
ist aber um wie viel also um 25 oder
eher um 50 basispunkte im september ist
die nächste sitzung dann wissen wir mehr
normalerweise bekommen die
erzeugerpreise nicht so viel
aufmerksamkeit weil es eben die preise
für gewerbliche produkte sind wenn sie
aber so wie jetzt durch die decke gehen
dann schaut man schon genauer hindernis
dürfte nur eine frage der zeit sein bis
diese preissteigerung auch bei den
verbrauchern ankommen und damit in der
inflationsrate die erzeugerpreise
steigen im rekordtempo im juli um 37
prozent gegenüber dem vorjahresmonat
größter preistreiber ist weiterhin die
energie vor allem erdgas und strom für
gewerbe und industrie zogen stark an
aber auch mineralöl- wurde deutlich
teurer tank rabatt und neun euro ticket
drücken derzeit die teuerung für die
verbraucher doch beides läuft am
monatsende aus experten rechnen daher im
herbst mit einer inflation von um die
neun prozent
die hohe inflation und die sorge vor
steigenden zinsen drückt auch auf die
stimmung an der börse der dax taucht ab
über 1 prozent und damit beendet er eine
ziemlich durchwachsene woche in -
nächste woche berät sich die
amerikanische notenbank über ihre
zinspolitik da lässt sie möglicherweise
weitere kräftige zinserhöhungen
durchblicken und das wäre dann
vermutlich der nächste dämpfer für die
aktienmärkte
valerie haller an der börse vielen dank
für die einordnung
sie war ein deutsch-deutscher star galt
als film die war der ddr die
schauspielerin sängerin und autorin eva
maria hagen am dienstag ist sie im alter
von 87 jahren gestorben in den 1950 er
wurde sie in ostberlin als
theaterschauspielerin bekannt als sie
1976 gegen die ausbürgerung ihres
lebensgefährten des liedermachers wolf
biermann protestiert
belegt wird das sed-regime sie mit
berufsverbot sie folgte ihm in die
bundesrepublik gemeinsam mit ihrer
tochter der punk sängerin nina hagen und
feierte weiter viele filmerfolge
zur schwimm-wm in rom beim
klippenspringen einer neuen sportart bei
den europameisterschaften hat iris
schmidt bauer aus oberbayern gold
gewonnen high diving nennt der
weltverband das klippenspringen frauen
springen dabei aus 20 metern höhe in
einen pool männer aus 27 meter höhe
und bei den european championships in
münchen haben die deutschen kanuten
einen regelrechten medaillenregen
eingefahren in drei von fünf
wettbewerben holten sie gold und damit
die em titel angeführt von kanu könig
sebastian brendel und tim hecke im
canadier zweier über 1000 meter und
das und das war es von uns für heute
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit dem opern
hit kamen aus der arena di verona und
direkt danach um 0.40 melde ich mich
wieder mit unserem heute-journal updates
uns gibt's morgen wieder einen schönen
abend und schießen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend dauerregen bis in den unwetter
bereich das brachte uns der tag und das
lag zum einen an diesem tief hier das
sich über dem golf von genua gebildet
hat diese generativ saugen ihre energie
und ihre feuchte aus dem mittelmeer
zumal das im ligurischen teil im moment
34 grad wärmer ist als im durchschnitt
das team zog dann richtung
süddeutschland und drehte hier die
windrichtung auf südöstlichen richtungen
das kleine tief an der grenze zu polen
allerdings hielt die windrichtung am
boden auf nordwest und das bedeutet wir
haben eine gegenstromanlage die südliche
luft steigt auf und hebung bedeutet in
der metrologie fast immer regen das
zeigt uns auch der aktuelle rada film
übrigens heute mittag auch noch einige
ordentliche schauer und gewitter über
dem nordosten das zog aber ab und dann
regnete es sich eben hier im süden
ordentlich ein schwerpunktmäßig war das
der fall zwischen mittelfranken dem
bodensee und a und dem allgäu in
günzburg bei ulm kamen seit heute morgen
über 100 liter regen cooper tat mit der
zusammen auch in ingolstadt gab es in
den letzten 24 stunden 102 liter pro
quadratmeter
jetzt seit dem abend verlagert sich das
ganze langsam ostwärts vorsicht also
weiterhin im südosten vor überflutungen
da können vereinzelt bis morgen noch
einmal 50 liter pro quadratmeter dazu
kommen übrigens ganz hier im westen da
sehen sie die harmlosen schauer einer
kaltfront die jetzt heute nacht auch im
westen weiter vorankommt dazwischen noch
trocken vom schwarzwald bis nach
schleswig-holstein dann haben wir eben
diesen unwetter bereich im südosten
einzelne schauer und gewitter können von
dort auch über das erzgebirge in den
osten aus greifen das ganze bei 11 grad
im dauerregen und 19 grad an der ostsee
morgen haben wir die gleiche
ausgangslage der gewittrige dauerregen
im südosten lässt aber im tagesverlauf
nach und dann folgt diese
vergleichsweise harmlose kaltfront im
end bringt die im westen und in der
mitte auch mal etwas regen dahinter gibt
es aber schon eine wetterberuhigung und
dazu haben wir 18 grad bei dichteren
wolken und 24 bis 27 grad im westen mit
dieser wetterberuhigung geht es auch in
den nächsten tagen weiter hier und da
gab es mal einen schauer größtenteils
bleibt es aber wieder trocken immerhin
bei angenehmen temperaturen zwischen 21
und 28 grad das war es von uns kommen
sie gut durch die nacht